oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well I mean those three are some of my
favorite reveals this season and we are
taking a trip down masked singer memory
lane tonight and going through all the
reveals of season three so far hey guys
I'm Charlie okie and I'm Deidre Behar
Charlie I miss you
Arlie still at home I'm still at home we
hope everybody out there is being
healthy and safe but like he just
mentioned tonight's episode is gonna be
a little different I'm really excited
because we're gonna gather together all
of the awesome et interviews that we've
done would be eliminated contestants so
far that's right well let's jump right
into it sadly the last competitor hopped
out of the competition a little too soon
and spoke to et right afterwards take a
look
[Applause]
sure
we really love the behind-the-scenes of
all the things masked singer can you
tell me a secret about either your
costume or something that was involved
with your process that no one would know
from watching it at home on TV eyes this
gel went on we kept adding more and more
bling to that costume more and more
chains it was a process because to blend
the chest hair with the head hair we
switched the phrase a couple times to
get the what is it called the road to
stay on we had a lot of different
synapse there were synapse like here
here here here so once I was snapped and
I was not using the restroom I was not
taking it off or anything until it was
time to be done our girl Jordan woods
opening up about all things masked
singer the full interview is available
online if you want to go watch it to get
the whole picture but I thought that
that little chunk was so interesting
like it's so much work getting into
these elaborate costumes that you
literally can't even go to the restroom
and I don't know about you but I've
thought about it before watching it
especially with like Drew Carey's
costume which had four legs how do you
go to the bathroom how do you get a
snack like these are all important
things people correct the spoiler alert
is that you you don't I just use you
deal with it well our next two
eliminated contestants may be the
highest energy performers in math
history let's take a look at the roaring
white tiger and t-rex
[Applause]
I love both of them so much I feel like
I just had seven shots of espresso after
a venti cold brew right so much caffeine
and energy and you know look I I know
Jojo is a singer Rob is not the cool
thing that these two contestants brought
is pure energy and it just proves you
don't have to be someone with a really
trained big voice like a will Wayne
Brady or an Adrian Houghton you can be
someone like Jojo or like Rob and you
can go out on the show and just show how
much fun you can have with it what do
you think exactly I agree I think they
brought that energy every week the
audience loved it people may have wanted
them to get voted out but I still
thought they gave great performances
that were fun to watch it at home and ET
online actually spoke to Jojo cy after
her elimination and she said she had 18
layers of clothing on underneath that
costume it was extremely intense it was
so fun
worth every second and she would do it
again in a heartbeat let's break down
those 18 layers I'm wearing that has to
be like four pairs of socks for the
shoes maybe I can't imagine it's like a
bow yes and I loved watching her perform
must have been so sweaty in there but
she made every minute count and had so
much fun doing it so well our next
performer didn't last too long this
season but she certainly showed us her
swan song capabilities and Deidre
actually caught up with her after the
elimination check it out
[Applause]
fake on me it's like it's like way out
of frame it's so feeling and I can only
see out of like you know the tiny little
eyeholes or whatever can barely see out
of those guys and then my mic hole in my
mass was just like not really giving the
whole vocals so I had to go in my
eyeholes you put your microphone up to
the eyeholes yeah so while I'm singing
just watch the playback like if you
watch it again and you're like wait yeah
she's totally not even is though good
those are literally her eyeballs haha
like I'm like a sometimes I really
couldn't see because I'd have to just
look with one eye yeah you know cuz yeah
it's totally covered by Mike abs you're
really interesting I have to say I feel
like I feel like the Swan got robbed a
little bit I agree you agree i I do
agree I think we could have seen her
sinks tomorrow night I wanted to hear
her sing lawyer well I think we all did
Bella mentioned in this interview that I
did with her she was like you know I'm
such a rock star she's kind of tomboyish
and so of course she picked the complete
opposite she wanted a graceful costume
like this one but she said she was gonna
sing the climb by Miley Cyrus if she had
continued in this competition and I
would have loved to have seen that you
know to go from singing a Joan Jett song
to a mildly valid just shows just what a
great performer she is and I feel like I
would have loved to have seen her in the
finale but Bella was a wealth of
knowledge if you want to know more
behind the scenes scoop about all things
Matt singer I encourage you to go to ET
online.com and watch hey Deidre what
does the former governor of Alaska and
one of America's most beloved television
hosts have in common I don't know
nothing listen we thought nothing until
they both appeared on the massacre
[Applause]
can we talk about the taco why a taco
well I was the last person cast in Group
V and by that point they only had two
choices obviously a taco costume the
other one was a jellyfish yeah so I
think I picked the right one was it hard
to get the taco that tomato mask on and
off the tomato mask was the easiest part
the hardest part was the hard shell taco
itself I had to get in one side and then
that goes around and you're in there i
shaking your hips in a taco shell ain't
happening a jellyfish a jellyfish which
i think is so exciting because I believe
we've seen a few costumes this season
that didn't make it from the first and
second season choices so the jellyfish
could be making it in season four maybe
I am so ready for sparkly tenderly
tentacles tendrils I don't know what
they are but again Tom Bergeron not
someone I knew who knew how to sing but
my lord he's like a Frank Sinatra
protege he's such a showman exactly they
need to get him and singing on Dancing
with the Stars well the people are
dancing that's what we pressure is on
and I have I have a question for you
yes a live one to ten ten being shocked
how shocked were you that Sarah Palin
was behind the bear a 42 I don't think
any of us expected a politician to take
that head off and when she did it was
just it was very very surprising but I
do have to say the door is now open for
politicians to join the masked singer
yeah
Michelle I am looking at you Malia Sasha
Chelsea Clinton Hillary Clinton make the
whole squad don't make all of them and I
think you know regardless of how you
feel about Sarah Palin politically you
have to give the woman props
she went out there and she memorized
these intricate fast lyrics to baby got
back a song I never in a million years
thought that she would be performing on
a show like this but I give her credit
for putting herself out there and doing
something new
I completely agree well up next we have
two legends from very different worlds
but still legends I might say
take a look
[Applause]
did your children figure out it was you
on the mast singer
well the immediate kids in the household
knew because I had told him what I was
doing when I was coming up to LA all the
time doing is alright we have three boys
in college they did not know what was
their reaction
what really you that kind of thing that
kind of thing like but they thought they
they were all complimentary yeah
surprisingly and you know you're not
generally dark coupling your dad that
much no Charlie could you imagine
talking to your parents on the phone
thinking nothing is wrong but secretly
they're spending ten hours a day
rehearsing in an elephant costume for a
singing show how wild is that it just
sounds absurd when you say it but that
is Tony Hawk's life this year you know
again I kind of like the point that we
brought up before never would have
thought I'd see Tony Hawk on a show like
this I had no idea he had an interest in
music or a passion for singing but he
was a tricky one I mean that was one
where you and I were like sitting at our
computers being like who the heck is
this exactly I think his kids didn't
really recognize it was him initially
because no one's heard him sing but that
definitely doesn't compare to the other
person we just saw miss Dionne Warwick a
legend known for her voice right so
she's someone who we've grown up
celebrating for decades and we know her
voice kind of like Miss Patty's as soon
as we heard it we knew it was her
but with Tony Hawk I just remember being
so frustrated like Google helped me what
do these clues mean and I will say no
one in our office couldn't figure out
that voice because we've never heard him
sing and I will Pat us both virtually on
the back here and say that we knew both
of these next contestants from their
first performance take a look at Miss
monster and the llama
[Applause]
there's a dresser that meets you in your
trailer that helps you get dressed them
to lead you out to the stage where you
have another little dressing room that's
curtain off so the crew doesn't see you
I've been telling the story because it's
crazy we had the same they wanted to
introduce them to the stage manager
first got there he's the guy that points
you like stand here and okay here very
important stage manager and this is
Jonathan your stage manager and it was
the same stage manager I had on The
Price is Right for four years did he
know no he didn't know no and I'm
telling you whoever the stage manager is
in a TV show nobody looks at you more
than that person so how wild is that
story about Drew Carey it's a very kind
of Hollywood insider studio secret so it
break it down for everyone exactly okay
so here in Los Angeles there's a lot
which is where a lot of TV shows get
filmed and the price is right which drew
hosts and the masked singer are right
next to each other
so I think they probably share a lot of
crew and a lot of staff members and for
drew to be completely decked out as the
llama working with a stage manager who
has known him inside and out for years
for that person to not know that it was
drew behind the mask just shows you the
insane level of secrecy on this show and
I think it's it's wild because when
you're working on a production or your
talent or your producer even a producing
assistant anything you work so closely
with the stage manager and everyone kind
of a running that tight ship so for drew
and that stage manager can never have
any direct contact or figure out that
it's him that's wild and it really does
go to show the level of secrecy that Fox
keeps for the show 100% and then of
course miss Chaka people kind of knew it
from the get-go that voice is so
recognizable and so iconic
but you know I thought it was cool that
she did her her own thing with the Miss
monster a play on on something we saw
from season one and I love her she
brought her energy I love her it's
another Patti LaBelle situation you
can't trick us we know a legends boy you
know a legend
and finally we have to end things with
our first and biggest post Super Bowl
super elimination check it out
well Charlie you and I were together the
night at the Super Bowl we were and we
didn't stop talking about Jennifer Lopez
and Shakira's halftime show we were
dancing like our energy was just through
the roof I know how we felt when we saw
Lil Wayne was revealed on the masked
singer again it goes back to espresso I
feel like we had 10 shots of espresso
that night it was so exciting to watch
because you know Lowell wouldn't he's a
rapper he's so cool and I don't know if
I'd necessarily associate him with doing
a show like this I was like wait it
sounds like him but would he really do
with the masses right here and I think
Fox really teased just saying that miss
first elimination is gonna be a big one
and we were definitely on the edge of
our seats
after JLo and Shakira and then we
couldn't stop talking about the masked
singer first elimination it was truly a
shocking one and I'm very happy you did
the show yeah but I'm still a little
angry we deserved more of low-weight on
this show I know I'm doing a ballad I
may be something that just would have
that would have been everything we need
in 2020 doing some sort of a pop star
imagine if Lil Wayne get a JLo cover
yeah I mean possibilities are endless
they are it's what the people want
yes all right guys so you've seen all
the reveals of the masked singer season
three so far and next week we'll be
getting back to business with a
brand-new episode and unfortunately
someone is going home it's either gonna
be the Rhino the kitty the banana or the
Frog Charlie I'm gonna count to three
word out who you think is going home
when I say three okay one two three
right now we're in agreement this is
good I mean not for the Rhino but this
is good for our gusting yeah we love who
we think is Barry Zito or as we
affectionately call him Barry tortellini
yeah but it's just it's you know the
banana the Frog the kitty they're all
such big performers yeah and the Rhino
has an amazing voice too but I I don't
know I think it might be the Rhinos time
I do too and although we didn't get new
performances tonight still send us your
guesses tweet us DM us comment
everything we want to hear from you guys
let us know who you think is gonna go
home next week after the second round
of knockouts of course stay home stay
safe
wash your hands we will be back next
week and we can't wait to see you guys
again bye guys
[Music]